phillies need zack wheeler to be a
stopper today no question about it tom i
mean and he has been absolutely dealing
and they really do need him today and he
has just been absolutely outstanding in
this month and at home i mean look at
the home numbers he in his five starts
2-0 record with a 202 era and in the
month of may just absolutely dominant
with the 186
era he has been dealing they need him to
be the ace that he is for the staff
tonight
one stolen base leads off first
swig it a miss 98 miles an hour
one away in the first strikeout for
wheeler
hernandez being held on by hoskins at
first
swinging a miss
98 devers is the second strikeout victim
eduardo five and two of 470 era last
couple have been kind of shaky yeah very
hittable really the last couple out he's
he's due for a bounce back start he's
got to locate a little bit better
he's 2-2
got him throw down that's going to
trickle
he's going to hold there at second base
herrera with the theft
on the strikeout so
two gone
hoskins the hitter he's been on base 22
of 24 at home this year including last
night when he hit his 100th career home
run
shoots it the other way that's going to
roll on the right field at base it
herrera is around third heading for home
and renfro who's one of the best
throwers in the league couldn't get the
ball out of his glove rbi single what do
you call that reuben a nice piece of
hitting
definitely one of those
i was wondering if we'd get through the
game without saying that but uh that was
a nice piece of hitting right there with
two strikes especially
reach out and poke that two-strike a 2-2
pitch in that big big hole over at
second base take that with that shift
[Applause]
and and that's a nice job and really
that's something that the phillies and
you'd like to see just happening across
the league rubbers will be off with the
count three and two with two outs here
in the bottom of the first phillies have
a run in on the rbi single by hoskins
pitches hit high in the air to left
field way back there marlon francie
cordero going back it's off the screen
it's a home run
offensive field home run for brad miller
and the phillies jump out on top
four nothing
it hit the screen just to the right of
the 329 side
how about that
99 home runs now for brad miller he
needs one for a hundred
2-2 pitch
swinging this he struck him out
third strikeout for
zach weiner one two three shut down
inning for the phil's right-hander we're
going to the second four-nothing
phillies
and strikes him out
although he swung at what would have
been ball four
and that's out number two and he was a
little upset with himself with chasing
that too that ball was way out of the
strike zone
very mellow on the mound i don't know if
there's a big difference
swinging has pulled the string there and
got him
so a much better inning he gets him one
two three in the second
zack wieder back to work here for the
third inning four nothing phillies the
pitch
swinging it missed fastball cordero and
reaching for yeah
not much chance there
the o2
swing
try it again that's a pitcher just
saying you know what i don't want to
just strike you out i'm going to
embarrass you again
and as we go to the fourth inning zach
wheeler will face danny santana rafael
devers and christian vasquez
swinging a miss at a high heater
he's mowed down six so far
and he just has a dominating fastball
right now and he's just blowing it right
past him gets the fastball up above the
swing plane right here and santana's got
no chance r-square here's the
right-hander's 2-2
fast ball strike three call got him
looking
and wheeler records strikeout number
seven there's another one two three
inning and after the lead off hit
in the first inning wheeler has now
retired 12 red sox in a row
2-2 is lined the other way of base it
for wheeler working the count
with a second straight at bat and that
puts runners on first and second with
two bend down he sheepishly does
the little exclamation point
i can't tell you how important it is for
a guy like a pitcher to be able to make
contact and have good at bats i mean it
turns the lineup over
adds more and more pitches to the
pitcher it gives andrew mccutcheon now
cuts got a chance to really do some
damage with you know
base runners on i think it's uh
[Music]
brings up marwyn gonzalez gonzalez
popped out
his first time up to left
wiener rocks into the wind in the
swing and this struck you now that's
strikeout number eight for wheeler two
outs nobody on
center field that is well
hit
herrera is going back the wind is going
to bring it back he makes the catch and
the inning is over
oh mother nature
up in the cause
seven pitches 15 in a row
it's still four nothing phillies as we
go to the bottom of the fifth
billy's four red sox nothing nobody out
bottom of the fifth inning and philly
threatening sawamura on o2
kwed disappeared he struck him out nice
work there by sawamura he inherited two
he gets the next three quickly
zach wheeler goes to work here at the
top of the sixth inning others lead off
first and second first time today there
have been two base runners on for the
red sox
swinging a foul tip hung on by nat 98
miles an hour he just challenged them
with a fourth seam fastball
the red sox are retired here in the
sixth inning no runs a hit too bad left
nine strikeouts for wheeler zach wheeler
he has been outstanding nine strikeouts
through six innings one and two
here's the pitch
swing i miss he struck him out
there's number 10 on the day for zach
weiner nasty slider it's his getting
ahead and putting him away with that
slider
swing and a miss take a little off yeah
he did the curveball for the 11th
strikeout today for zach wheeler he has
been absolutely masterful
here this afternoon against the boston
red sox well wheeler back out there for
the eighth inning he has allowed two
singles and struck out 11 francie
cordero
will swing and hit a high fly ball that
one is going to be jacked way out of
here
an absolute shot by franchi and that's
how you break up a shutout and he got it
all yeah everybody's down in the zone
too nobody moved the whole ballpark this
move just watched it everybody everybody
out on the field did not move how about
that for your first home run as a member
of the red sox
that's an impressive home run
look at the miss that matches his career
high in strikeouts 12 strikeouts for
wheeler here comes joe girardi wheeler
is going to get a very nice round no
applause for the 15
360 here today
the phillies needed a lift from their
starting pitcher
and they got one
way over his head
and now herrera who has two hits
he's two for three
line drive left field cordero is not
gonna get it it's gonna go to the wall
one is in joyce will be held at third
rbi double for o'duba herrera six to one
philly's on top
ten in a row and for the red sox they
have begun
43 consecutive days in sole possession
that one's going to be knocked over the
wall for a home run
going to the opposite field rafael
devers destroys that one red sox have
hit a couple of home runs in the last
two innings number 13 for raphael
that'll make it six to two yeah that was
a laser shot right there
3-2 pitch
ground ball back toward the middle
segour is there the second baseman
throws over to first in time
and the ball game is over the phillies
salvage a three-game series they win it
six to two